Oh
[Music]
all big movie genres have life cycles
they're born they become popular they
exhaust themselves and then if they're
important enough they transform Hugh
Jackman 17-year tenure as Wolverine
I think bookends to important milestones
in the superhero film shop 2000s x-men
directed by Bryan Singer was effectively
the start of the superhero craze that
come to dominate Hollywood for nearly
two decades and now 2017 s Logan
directed by James Mangold represents a
response to the public's exhaustion of
that dominance if you want to understand
how John Rah's change the writer to look
at is definitely John koel T whose
famous essay on generic transformation
is I think a good rubric for what's
happening in Logan Co LT is basically
interested in what occurs when Jean
ricchan vention 's become so well known
that the audience demands something new
what forms does that change take a
wealthy identifies for burlesque
nostalgia d mythologize ation and
reaffirmation burlesque is essentially a
ridiculous exaggeration or parody of
genre conventions it's initially a
braudys quote from the start of this
video genres turned to self parody to
say well at least if we can make fun of
it for being infantile it will show how
far we've come
Mel Brooks is of course a master is this
kind of saying and not just for westerns
moments of the less can be found in
serious movies too when a trope is made
to suddenly look ridiculous undercutting
the fantasy with reality and the
superhero genre Deadpool film that
helped pave the way for Logan is a
burlesque through and through superhero
landing you're going to do a superhero
ladder
wait for it
whoa superhero landing that's really
hard on your knees totally impractical
I'll do it
nostalgic films the ones that are good
anyway do more than evoke a romanticized
past they update tried-and-true
storylines with contemporary elements
they make the audience aware of the
relationship between past and present
co.ltd sites True Grit but Shane Black's
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang fits the bill as
well a hard-boiled detective story in
which many of the tropes Sardi
romanticized but the story ultimately
follows the same beats of discovery and
heroism
although demonologist films are the most
complex of the bunch they subject
popular myths and conventions to a
reality that undercuts and exposes them
as inadequate or even harmful who lt's
archetypal example of this is Roman
Polanski's Chinatown a film that follows
the hard-boiled detective genre of
classic films like The Maltese Falcon or
the big sleep until events become so
dark and twisted and devoid of moral
content that justice is never served and
the detective is left severely
traumatized another movie like this
would be the Coen brothers No Country
for Old Men in which the lawmen of the
new West Tommy Lee Jones not only fails
to capture the villain what fails to
understand him I don't want those BOTS
to absorb and though I out have made
something I don't understand the final
transformation is the reaffirmation of
myth the kind of film that subverts
genre like the DeMuth ala Joe's film
what in the end chooses to reaffirm the
myth not as something that's real but as
something that we need to believe I
wonder if you can think of a superhero
film that might fall into that category
so what is Logan clearly it represents
some shift in this extraordinarily
popular genre it's Deadpool signals a
self-awareness that the myth of the
superhero movie is losing a bit of its
power then I think Logan is an attempt
to interrogate the contours of that myth
in order to see if there are any
interesting directions left for it to go
director james mangold is a movie buff
and something that's really interesting
about Logan is how he uses one genre to
understand another mangled States
Logan's key theme via a scene from Shane
one of the most popular and acclaimed
westerns of all time that has to be what
it is Jony can't break them I tried it
didn't work for me Shane Joey there's no
living with but a killing as well going
back westerns are really the perfect
genre to measure the superhero movie the
myth of the superhero is in many ways a
reincarnation of the myth of the
gunslinger both are heroes who act
outside the law to protect the community
at large mangled makes these parallels
explicit in a sequence midway through
the movie when Logan Charles and Lara
are taken in by a kindly family the same
way that Shane is taken both Logan and
chain helped the family with work and
protect them from greedy business
interests but though Shane is somewhat
haunted by his life as a gunslinger his
purpose and the code of laws he lives by
is still necessary to protect the
community in the end in mangled version
the violence that follows the hero can't
be contained far from the valley being
saved
Logan's kindly family is mercilessly and
utterly destroyed and if the point
wasn't clear it's by none other than a
clone of Logan himself this is the
closest that Logan comes to
demythologize ation the whole movie is a
meditation on the violence that all
superhero films imply by earning an
r-rating mangled and Jackman get to show
a type of visceral brutality that
complicates the heroics of Logan's past
as well as those of the x-men and all
superheroes like it does Shane Logan
holds up the romanticized past of
previous superhero movies in the form of
comic books you do know they're all
[ __ ] right
a record of it happens another this
Logan is attempting to expose the
inadequacy of these fantasies trying to
show that no personal moral code can
wield power without risking devastation
this is made painfully clear in the
character of Xavier who's aging mind
it's implied may have unintentionally
killed a number of innocent mutants for
Logan himself the past exploits of
heroism from the other movies we emerges
as trauma and nightmare a touching scene
with Lara near the end he even admits to
contemplating suicide actually I am
listening I'm shooting myself hi Charles
hood
in the end Logan makes the final turn
into reaffirmation one last act of
sacrificial heroics that reaffirms the
miss even after exposing it as
inadequate you know it makes me wonder
if this is the limit of superhero movies
it's unclear whether a film that sought
to fully be mythologize this myth could
ever really get made or if the genre
itself is even mature enough to handle
such a thing in fact I think Logan
leaves us with these exact questions the
movie itself is a conversation between
nostalgia for this genre and our
increasing frustration with its limits
more than anything I'm just excited for
what's to come because it's transition
periods like these as a wealthy might
say when the really interesting things
you get back everybody thank you so much
for watching subscribe to this channel
for more videos this episode was brought
to you by audible audible has a huge
selection of digital audiobooks which I
love to listen to when I'm stuck in Los
Angeles traffic for hours and hours and
hours you might as well make that time
worthwhile in honor of the new series
I'm going to recommend Neil Gaiman
American Gods as read by game and
himself and a cast of great actors it's
an extraordinary book and if you go to
audible.com slash nerdwriter you can get
a 30-day free trial and one free
audiobook so you can use that on
American Gods or something else enjoy
thanks guys I'll see you next time